à vous aimer la nostalgie julien vous
l'appréciez que j'ai vu l'émotion sur le
visage que vous m'avez vu enfant a huit
ans avec ma mèche rebelle et ma tête à
claques et surtout ce que j'ai moi aussi
à nostalgie aujourd'hui on n'a plus eu
huit ans mais on va jouer au jeu auquel
je jouais quand j'avais huit ans avant
des jeux flash à l'époque je jouais sur
absolue flash et le site n'existe plus
et pas de panique les jeux flash ça
existe toujours on va jouer à une petite
flopée de ces derniers et cela va nous
divertir
ah bah pourquoi ne pas tout tu t'es dans
les meilleurs jeux de la semaine fidget
speed non non ne me dit pas non mais non
c'est non c'est un nom c'est un gros nom
énervé détruisez cette bannière oui je
le fais je fais ça m'avait l'air bon
gars ton [ __ ] d'espinar je l'appelle à
quoi derrière me dis pas qu'il est
mineur derrière un [ __ ] de merde
la reda c'est quoi ça mais vous avez
brisé des enfants cela mon gars la reine
des glaces chez le dermatologue
mais qu'est ce qui se passe sur ce site
en plus c'est la reine des glaces mexes
et là des verrues elle peut se
débrouiller elle même avec le froid la
zone tels le crée la reine des glaces ok
bon hein on va t'aider on va t'aider
voilà on vous retire tes petits boutons
1 pas ça va aller ça elle est inquiète
pas ta maman ne te considère plus comme
ça sur sait tous que c'est ça ma
décision à l'été prenant plus d'accord
c'est pas que tu as un problème de deux
boutons la sépaq au delà paula on a des
relations nana barberin abardia jeux
faits connexes à un nom onu laséristes
la peau mais ça va pas + tincani cas
mais c'est le traitement de vrais
problèmes de peau sa mecque de te mettre
un sabre laser sur la gueule à bas
puisqu'il a pris dark vador va avoir
beaucoup d'acteurs qui a été pas mal
puisque est ta vie avait un petit
sous-entendus et tout mais non non
m'arrête et en plus elle a des bactéries
avec j'espère moins qu'à la fin on se
rappelle un peu plus jamais avoir brisé
le coeur ok niveaux suivants atik listes
émanant de tous pour lui mettre des
coups de pied pour retirer son techno à
bah oui bah oui un pistolet laser mec ça
retire de ouf je crois que je pense je
trop à coeur d'oublier singe est destiné
aux enfants de 6 ans à peu du tout ok il
ya des araignées oh [ __ ] c'est fini
nous regarde pas comme ça je n'ai rien
fait de la tortue de quoi en fait si je
clique beit pour enfants dans l'enfant
il voit la reine des neiges avec une
peau ignoble et ou avec marquez est de
l'aed life et il clique pour l'année
puisqu'il y croit le l'enfant [ __ ]
c'est scandaleux
ah les opérations j'aime bien ça c'est
drôle ça êtes vous prêt à avoir envie de
vous flinguer
c'est parti nous attendons le bloc
désinfecter vous les mains beau père et
c'est parti n'essaie pas de reproduire
ça chez toi vous pensez qu étant enfant
on aurait pu se dire stop à dire je vais
essayer sur toi paris comme ça qu'on le
sent fort aujourd'hui notre passion de
sa peine marc wilson de retour à l'école
après les vacances allez remarquer que
sa vision était trouble un ophtalmologue
lui a diagnostiqué une opacification du
cristallin également connu sous le nom
de cataracte
c'est ma grand mère qui a eu sa elle
doit remplacer le cristallin opacifié
dans une zone par un cristallin
artificiel ça lui permettra de revoir
comme avant à c'est exactement ce que ma
grand mère a eu anesthésie locale as
avec des gouttes les espèces locales
pour les yeux c'est cool ça change de
l'énorme aiguilles de 8 cm compte en
fondant la pompe ok on nettoie voilà au
[ __ ] de la grc ou samedi j'ai besoin
que d'un coup on va découvrir un truc
bizarre
il nous faut un spéculum pour maintenir
ses yeux ouverts le moindre clément que
l'opération pour avoir des conséquences
désastreuses et mais le début [ __ ] ça
c'est les fesses on va commencer par une
petite incision dans la forme et c'est
parti un mec ça me met dans des sites
cette merde alors que c'est des dessins
je crois que je connais déjà fait un jeu
en vidéo en plus cette opération tout
cas c'est dégueulasse c'est ignoble on
l'a déjà fait je m'en souviens être suis
en train de deux on arrête tour à tous
là on s'en bat les couilles de la
passion avec souvient on s'en fout on a
déjà fait cette opération vous rendez
compte pas oublier c'est peut-être mon
cerveau opération dégage
momo poyaud c'est quoi ça il ya
tellement une grosse flopée de jeux
poillion muya après hagard you est tous
là qu'est ce que je dois faire c'est
quoi ce jeu dominé mais non mais t'es
sérieux là ma vie c'est ça mon boxeur
quand j'aurai terminé dominé doit avoir
pouvoir de ouf après regardez bien
regardez bien de fait me suis cassé les
couilles pour rien ou le thé morts tiens
mais put je clique dans la fenêtre
pourquoi ça se frôlent la pâle
mais non le rêve drift rohner troisième
est qu'il est sorti ça fait deux ans et
demi que j'attends que je sorte mais
qu'attend ne me dis pas on va pouvoir
rester avec des voitures en 3d s'il te
plaît
oh mon dieu tu passes une vitesse a fait
le bruit des portes d'un bus qui souffre
c'est génial
le premier rendez vous des lits en
[ __ ] il est pêché il faut absolument
qu'on réussisse à séduire comment va
s'éprendre salué les jeter repérer à
l'école ça diraient qu'on sorte en
sommes aujourd'hui à celui sur qui j'ai
vu me propose de sortir avec lui
aujourd'hui j'avoue abîmé j'arrive pas
faire la fab et moi peut préparer pour
neutre ou premier rendez vous au la
[ __ ] mais côté là quelle tenue on va
mettre pour elie à la coupe cheveux
courts allez hop la coupe rennes un
petit jean avec des trous ou un petit
short il fait chaud c'est l'été le haut
avec le puck bien évidemment et la
petite veste rose comme ça c'est très
bien le petit bob l'eponge et le bandana
c'est parti et l'appareil photo pour
mener à bien notre blog bien sûr nous
passons maintenant au maquillage sims
c'est que c'est pas cliché du tout
j'adore un poêle de masse
quaas à moi de me maquiller avec la
souris d'accord et voilà ça suffira
juste mascara la beauté naturelle le
touchera en plein coeur t'en vas si je
m'en fous moi je vois comment ça se
passe et laurent des bouquets le moment
qu'on attend tous leurs rendez vous
comment ça se passe et nous amener des
fleurs à temps c'est tout c'est juste
une image non non non non non non non
non et non
maintenant je m'en bats les couilles la
télécharger mais non mais non
quelle arnaque s'éveilla junte [ __ ]
c'est quoi ce truc qui s'est ouvert aux
dires un cauchemar c'est que des trucs
ou faut habiller des filets maquiller ou
leur mettre du vernis mec ça dégage
alors
à jeu de chasse deer hunter ne me dis
pas qu'on va pouvoir chasser des cerfs
et des biches ne me dis pas ça qu'on la
terreur est chaud bouillant
[Musique]
on a testé d'amour mekkaoui j'entre mon
nom lucas j'entre son nom maxence
[Musique]
on est pour fatima 4 5% en amour au même
la caméra est jalouse à l'aise s'est
arrêté attendez bien elie qui est de
retour et qui veut qu'on se prépare
ensemble
kate reddy with me oh tu vas nous faire
what's in my phone tags mais attends tu
crois que si je prends des morceaux de
vidéos devraient youtube beauté et que
je l'aimé par dessus le gameplay on va
croire kelly nous fait une vidéo là
commence par appliquer ma petite crème
pour le visage surtout mon visage voilà
comme ça c'est fait et ça laisse le
temps ma peau de bien faire pénétrer la
crème pendant que je ferai autre chose
qu'on passe aux sourcils puis la poudre
j'utilise ensuite le mascara et vous
allez voir le rendu qui donne sur mes
cils c'est assez dingue on voit là
c'était une journée un petit peu comme
les autres on va dire aux samoa non ça
va c'est la nouvelle que tu peux ce qui
fait le buzz sur internet c'est élire
maximum dès maintenant pour elie et bien
voilà ta vie c'est la fin de cette vidéo
sur ces différents jeux flash périodes
plus calmes n'hésitez pas deux mais
comme d'habitude
eh bien écoutez les jeux flash ça a bien
changé je suis impressionné par le
nombre de jeux ou peu juste habillée ou
maquillée une piste incroyable bref
c'est le moment d'arrêter d'être
nostalgique et se dire au revoir à
bientôt
[Musique]
waouh